I know that a lot of crazy things have been
normalized during the Trump era, but what
is in John Bolton's book is blowing everything
else out of the water.
I don't know how else to say it now that we've
talked about the bogus attempts to suppress
the release of John Bolton's book.
I want to talk about what is actually in the
book.
And it is I mean, listen, I don't want to
be hyperbolic, but the sum total of what Bolton
alleges in this book essentially blows every
other Trump scandal out of the water.
And as usual, if only five percent of what
Bolton says in the book is true, it's worse
than we ever imagined.
That's that's the sort of math of it.
Now, let's get right into the insanity.
John Bolton asserts in his book that in twenty
nineteen at the G20, Chinese President Xi
explained to Donald Trump that he is essentially
building concentration camps to imprison this
Muslim population in China.
The Uighurs.
And according to the interpreter present for
that conversation, Donald Trump said to the
Chinese president that the camps should be
built and that it is the right thing to do.
Donald Trump allegedly okayed concentration
camps for China's Muslim population.
In a conversation with the Chinese president,
according to John Bolton, this was not an
isolated incident.
Bolton claims in his book that the top Asia
staffer for the National Security Council,
Matthew Pottinger, told him that in 2017,
Trump said the exact same thing about the
concentration camp camp for the Uighurs are
wiggers.
I'm not exactly sure the preferred pronunciation
there.
This is obviously a completely unconscionable
thing for Donald Trump to say.
But what's bonkers is that this is only the
tip of the iceberg with John Bolton's book.
Bolton claims that on multiple occasions,
Donald Trump said he was willing to help end
criminal investigations into major companies
in China and Turkey as favors to Presidents
Xi and Irda one.
Bolton alleges that Trump privately told him
that reporters deserve prison and in some
cases should be executed because they are,
quote, scumbags.
The allegation is that the president of the
United States said reporters, members of the
media should be either imprisoned or executed
for their reporting.
John Bolton alleges that Donald Trump lacked
just basic foreign policy knowledge.
Like as an example, Bolton says Trump didn't
know that the United Kingdom has nuclear weapons.
Donald Trump reportedly asked whether Finland
is part of Russia.
Donald Trump reportedly said it would be cool
to invade Venezuela.
Bolton recalled that White House Chief of
Staff John Kelly told that story.
According to the book, during Trump's 2018
meeting with the North Korean dictator Kim
Jong un, Trump's own secretary of state, Mike
Pompeo, slipped a note to Bolton, saying Trump
is full of S. Months later, Pompeo allegedly
dismissed Trump's entire North Korea gambit
as having a, quote, zero probability of success.
Meanwhile, Pompeo publicly was saying Trump's
doing a great job on North Korea.
There's an entire additional set of claims
in Bolton's book that has to do with Donald
Trump asking the Chinese president to help
him win in 2020.
Now, this is particularly stunning because
you might remember we covered this when it
happened.
George Stephanopoulos from ABC actually interviewed
Donald Trump and asked him, would you call
the FBI if Russia tried to help you in 2020,
if China tried to help you?
And Trump said, well, I might, but I also
might look at the information.
I might accept it.
Remember this clip?
This is somebody that said we have information
on your opponent.
Oh, let me call the FBI.
Give me a break.
Life as a director says that's what should
happen.
The FBI director is wrong.
Your campaign this time around is foreigners.
If Russia, if China if someone else offers
you information upon it, should they accept
it or should they call the FBI?
I think maybe you do both.
I think you might want to listen.
I don't there's nothing wrong with listening.
If somebody called from a country in Norway,
we have information on your opponent.
I think I'd want to hear you want that kind
of interference in our elections.
It's not an interference.
I have information.
I think I'd take it if I thought there was
something wrong.
I'd go maybe to the FBI if I thought there
was something wrong.
But when somebody comes up with oppo research,
right, they come up with our research.
Oh, let's call the FBI.
The FBI doesn't have enough agents to take
care of it.
But you go and talk honestly to congressmen.
They all do it.
They always have.
And that's the way it is.
It's called oppo research.
Well, it turns out that this was not merely
theoretical for Donald Trump.
Trump actually went to the Chinese president,
according to Bolten, and asked for help.
And the way Trump asked President Xi for help
was to explain.
Listen, President, sheep farmers are really
important to my reelection in 2020.
I need you to help me get reelected by making
larger purchases of soybeans and wheat from
the United States farmers.
So this is not just from accepting information.
This is not just Trump accepting help.
This is Trump asking for help to get reelected.
Lastly, for today on the claims in the book,
and we couldn't possibly cover everything
that's in the book.
Bolton says that Donald Trump regularly made
it clear that there was an obvious and overt
quid pro quo with Ukraine.
Bolton says Trump would regularly say don't
send any aid to Ukraine until we get the materials
about Hillary Clinton and Joe Biden.
So, again, we're going to talk more about
John Bolton being a traitor in a little bit.
You don't have to believe John Bolton is a
good person because he's not.
You don't have to excuse John Bolton's sic
role as an architect of the Iraq war.
Realize that if even five percent of what
he says in the book is true, this is the most
insane story or set of allegations about Donald
Trump from the beginning.
John Bolton has done many bad things.
But Bolton.
I don't believe it's just going to make up
all of this stuff out of thin air when you
realize that nothing that Bolton claims is
out of character with Trump.
That also is part of the picture here.
Now, why didn't John Bolton say it seven months
ago?
Why didn't John Bolton show up and say it
in front of the House impeachment committee?
Bolton should have told us sooner.
And he's even sicker because of the fact that
he didn't.
We are going to get to that later on in the
program.
He is not going to be excused, fought for
that.
But the claims are absolutely and completely
stunning.
And the fact that Bolton waited to do it in
a book is pathetic.
And it's just part of Bolton's worldview.
Which big picture?
I completely disagree with.
Let me know your reaction to the assertions
on Twitter.
I'm on Twitter at David Pakman.
And later, we will talk about how we should
judge Bolton for how he decides to do all
of this.